boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on
really excited we are still at triple-a
the American Anthropological Association
we are at the annual meeting we are now
sitting down with dr. Jason de Lyonne
hey man hey thanks for coming on to the
show thanks for having me greatly
appreciate it this is gonna be a lot of
fun
Jason is at the forefront of the the
undocumented migration project and that
is one of many interests of yours but
you're the program chair for the Triple
A annual meeting so that that means
you're coordinating what exactly it that
means if if you love your time slot for
your paper and then that's I did that if
you hate it
it's also my fault but I will pass the
buck to somebody else so we do a lot of
the programming the selection of the
keynote lectures the development of the
theme for the meeting which this year
it's resistance resilience and
adaptation and then all the physical
scheduling of every single session so
which happens by hand two days in DC of
damn hundreds of different sessions that
you move across a day of timetable of
five days yeah Wow so that that's a
tremendous we have work and then he's
also an associate professor and director
of undergraduate studies of anthropology
at the University of Michigan focus on
violence materiality death mourning
Latin American migration crime and
forensic analysis and archaeology of the
contemporary and so the undocumented
migration projects crazy
there was this backpack wall photo that
I'm gonna put into the feed of right now
for you guys to see and it's a long-term
study of clandestine border crossing
they uses ethnographic archaeological
and forensic approaches to understand
the phenomena a variety of geographical
context including Sorority Sonoran
desert of southern Arizona the Mexico
border towns north Mexico border towns
in southern Mexico Guatemala border you
also won the MacArthur Genius award last
year last year that's so cool I'm gratz
Congrats and I let's okay let's talk
about this this is this is really
interesting
first just give us a bit on like how
does one even get interested
anthropology and archeology how'd you
pick it up well you know it's funny we
had an event on Wednesday with George
Lucas and I was privileged to introduce
him to the audience one of the things I
talked about was the fact that when I
was a little kid you know I wanted to
have a bullwhip wear a fedora you know
jump into tombs
all because of the influence of Indiana
Jones and so for me I mean and and
that's really you know supposed to tell
the students I mean because the whole
idea of teaching anthropology is to
assume that hey it's not that it's it's
something much deeper and much more
nuanced but my kind of entryway into
archeology really was through through
Indiana Jones but as a kid I was
fascinated with history my family in
Mexico so we would put a lot of time
visiting Mexico and I had went to I
visited the pyramids of Teotihuacan when
I was a kid which just blew me away I
didn't know what it was but I knew that
I wanted to have some kind of connection
to that you know 15 years later I ended
up studying anthropology and archeology
as a college student this is a
combination of Indiana Jones and also
the X being introduced to some of the
largest historical yeah yeah Wow
now as you wouldn't you start professing
at the University of Michigan I started
University Michigan in 2010 2010 so
eight years now yeah and what has been a
fascinating sort of take away from
working with now probably thousands of
students over here eight years so like
yeah what's been some of your most fun
takeaways about what the process of
trying to educate students is like well
you know for me I was a total screwup
student I was a terrible student I
failed enjoyed archeology I have an F on
my transcripts and in the colonial
Indians in Mexico I got a C and intro to
anthro into intro to cultural
anthropology so my introduction of the
discipline was was kind of bad and it
was through it these amazing mentors who
kind of helped me to find my way and
gave me lots of support and
responsibilities that really shaped me
early on for me the the what I love
about my job when one of the biggest
parts of it is to be able to give that
back to students and so I love I take I
you know I've taught thousands of
students over the years but I've taken
hundreds of students to the field
so I work with a lot of undergraduates
and graduate students and for me that's
one of the the most rewarding parts of
this job is to be able to to give
something back to those to those those
folks and hopefully inspire them to do
you know to do anthropology and what you
just said about going to the field is so
important because you there's video
footage of you you know going through
the desert area of where the border is
and seeing the leftover artifacts of the
migration and when you expose young
people's minds to that process of
actually going and doing the archeology
themselves then they gain that same
awareness expansion now are you taking
students then from Michigan down there I
have been yeah but I take students from
although I mean I run field schools that
are international so we get students
from Mexico Canada you know sometimes a
Europe but but from all over the United
States
so some Michigan students and people
from other from other places as well and
then and then that that seems to be a
huge one so the fieldwork itself seems
to another huge part what was speaking
of resilience being the annual meeting
topic what about your resilience how did
you get through the C and the F and how
did you ever cyst you know I I was an
army brat so when I was a kid I moved
around a lot and I think what I didn't
realize was I was really being trained
to insert myself into different cultural
settings and figure out how to be
competent in those place it had to be
comfortable and how to how to how to get
to know people who were very different
from me and so I think that that early
on prepared me for a lot of what I ended
up doing as a as a researcher and when
it came down to being in school you know
it was is terrible College soon I
dropped out many times and it got to the
point where you know I had been a
musician for many years and I dropped
out I wanted to be a rock star I went on
tour totally failed had to come back
with you know my tail between my legs
and go back to college and it was kind
of like failing at music and my choice
was either to move in with my
grandmother which was like I'd rather go
to jail or to go back to school and so I
went back to school finally with real
seriousness after these absentees others
were
things and I was convinced by my mentors
that these things that I love travel
being around people of different
backgrounds I could do all the things
within the discipline of anthropology
and that was what really kind of helped
me to get over the hump of these early
failures but part of I think my early
failures was the fact that I was
oftentimes taught an archaeology that
just didn't connect with me it's it felt
very distant and foreign and you know I
grew up in an era where we were still
showing like the grainy footage of naked
you know brown people from from some
third-world country and that wasn't it
that was an apology for me that I
recognized as problematic and it wasn't
until someone pointed out to me that
like look there's other types of types
of work that you can do that really is
not that is the complete opposite of
that but can be inspiring and can be
really fulfilling when I found those
people and found that that subject
matter then I just hit the ground
running and you know it was just the
matter of having the having good
mentorship and and really being inspired
but I you know I think that for me it's
important to talk about those failures
to students because you know and not
everybody you know not everybody needs
to go to college I mean I sort of didn't
have a lot of job skills and I was like
okay well I'm obviously a terrible
musician I'm not I'm not gonna make a
living doing that so what else am I good
at I'm super good at hanging out I'm
super good at with being with with
people and so I was able to kind of
build a career out of that
and I think and much of my work is about
connecting with with people and trying
to understand their stories and to
highlight these experiences that we have
as as humans you nailed it you have the
teaching about failure which is crucial
building that resilience then you found
what you love because you had a
mentorship you're an inspiration and so
exposing young people to as many of
these options for things for them to
fall in love with as possible it's so
crucial that equality to opportunity and
then and then how did how did it end up
being that you studied the tools of
Latino tools Mexican tools yeah well so
my my initial training was in
archaeology and so I my dissertation was
on ancient stone tools
I wrote a 800 page the horrible horribly
boring tome about stone tools
and I had been really in love with
archaeology up to that point and I found
like I kind of lost my way in the middle
of it and I ended up doing this project
that didn't really feel fulfilling
because I felt like I had written this
book that six people in the world would
want to read maybe one of them is my mom
and that's about it you know but I feel
like I'd become too focused and I had
lost sight of the people and so I made
it I made a shift you know I finish my
dissertation and was like I never want
to look at a stone tool again I want to
do something else and I had been really
inspired by a lot of the folks who I'd
worked with on these excavations so men
and women in Mexico who had had these
traumatic border-crossing experiences
and I found that over the course of all
these years of excavating in Mexico I
was increasingly more interested in what
in what they had to say than about what
was coming out of the ground
and so that ended up being kind of lucky
- to find a project on immigration and
on border crossings that allows me to be
with people and to do Aetna graphic work
but also to use art that the tools of
archeology to document these experiences
and to collect these things in to
archive them we have we've had dr. David
Eagleman on the show who's a
neuroscientist and he had this similar
moment when he was exploring how he
could publish these very deeply nuanced
neuroscience papers that six people in
the world would need
and then he decided to start making new
senses for the human body
and so these sort of like augmentations
that can get to you know a hundred and
thirty million deaf people around the
planet right sue so this sort of how can
you you know you decided for you you
were like I'm gonna talk about something
I'm gonna research something that
undocumented project that hundreds of
millions of people are gonna be
interested in learning about rather than
the six even though ancients little
tools that is a different color on the
color wheel there is that interest for
people as well I just find that to be
very interesting that people care about
what other people will find interest
very deeply moving and interesting
okay so now let's talk about how you
know you're going down you're having
these these Mike you're you're literally
migrating people to an area of other
people's migration yeah for periods of
like these are long periods of time of
going through and excavating for
artifacts and so yeah teaches about what
all of that is like so my work is a mix
of you know part of it is being in the
Arizona desert collecting the things
that migrants are left behind doing
archaeological survey hiking in the
desert with with students to document
these these places and these trails and
then in other parts of it you know it
could be I do that for two months and
then it could be I spend two months in a
migrant shelter talking to folks about
their experience of doing interviews
about what's happened to them in the
deserts and and one of them those things
are interesting in and of themselves but
I think they're much more powerful when
I put them when I put them together and
but so but my typical day I mean it
could be I'm in the desert all day
hiking it could be I'm sitting in the
deportation court taking notes it could
be I'm doing interviews of migrants in
northern Mexico it could be I'm running
forensic experiments with using pigs as
proxies for the human body out in the
desert to understand what happens to the
dead people it could be that I'm in
Ecuador or New York traveling to meet
with the families of the missing or the
dead so it's a it's a interdisciplinary
project that allows me to kind of bounce
around and and for me that's really to
be able to kind of follow these stories
is really it's really helpful for me to
kind of get to get a better
understanding of the entire picture
because I think the deserts one part of
it there's so many other pieces of it
and and I think people would joke too
that I'm a bit
it's like Jack the jack of all master of
none Ram but constantly bouncing around
but for me like interesting research you
you have to do these things because one
thing alone is not gonna it's not gonna
give you all the information that you
need
there was a section where I was looking
at what you you know that you were
really trying to prove to some people
was that people that have undocumented
documented lis migrated to the United
States or to Guatemala that that they
are human they have lives they have
histories and so when we dehumanize
others we do humanize ourselves and so
it's time to eat to look at and care at
what why you know in the Y the Y is so
interesting too so I want to also ask
you about you know you're talking about
literally capturing someone's soul by a
photo of their of them looking at a
camera and telling their story like why
did they move why did they leave and
like you know tell us about that about
what you've been learning from these
interviews and yeah well you know for me
it's it really has become this
commitment to people and a commitment to
to showing people that that there's a
lot of suffering in the world and
needless suffering and you know we are
bombarded with statistics about
immigration we're bombarded with this
kind of polarizing rhetoric about you
know the the brown invader the immigrant
the you know the foreigner and that's
not helpful I think that's so
problematic from so many reasons and I
think it's it's a mask for these other
anxieties and so for me it's I'm
committed to people and I think
anthropology is a tool that can show
that we have a hell of a lot more in
common than we don't that we do of
difference and you know being with
people for me is really important and
I've also just been incredibly moved by
the things that I've seen and the people
that I've encountered and a lot of my
work has focused on on those who died in
the Arizona desert people who gets who
end up who are funneled into the Arizona
desert because that's a through Border
Patrol infrastructure that tries to use
the desert as a natural impediment to to
movement and we've been doing that for
20 years it's killed thousands of people
and I'll tell you what I mean it's one
thing to look at the names of the dead
that you can find online or to read the
statistics it's another thing to find a
dead body dam and to be like okay this
is as real as it gets and so for me you
know having those encounters
with the dead out there just really
confirm that this is what I need to be
doing and it's not just here is this
dead body look at you know gawk at this
corpse but who was she who was where did
she come from where is her family why
was she out here and what are the
repercussions of this death so for me
that's really my kind of goal is to to
make visible these things that are
happening right now
and with with with the hope that if we
know more about the stuff and we have a
deeper understanding of it then we won't
be fooled by this rhetoric that says
immigrants are horrible they're terrible
people they're here to destroy this
country it's like no these are just
people these are people trying to
survive people who are trying to make a
living and improve their situation and
we need to treat them with the amount of
respect that we want ourselves to be
treated and you know I've never had to
be in a situation where I need to cross
the desert to feed my family I don't
know what I would do but but I want
people to understand that these are not
easy choices that folks are having to
make and and really we should be ashamed
that thousands of people have died on US
soil and many of them will never be
identified because the Arizona desert
just quickly destroys destroys people's
bodies it becomes a whole dis entire
conversation it became so much different
because of the actual visualization that
you've put in me and likely with other
people of actually seeing dead bodies
that are just gone with nature really
quickly from the desert after in I want
I want you to give us a bit of an
explanation at what you think are the
the variables that are pushing
geopolitical economic political whatever
they are that are pushing people to make
the decision to attempt to to go through
this crazy circumstance of migration
yeah well you know for a long time I
mean the the easiest explanation was you
know the economy I mean NAFTA in the
mid-90s crashed the Mexican economy and
forced all these poor farmers who could
no longer make a living growing corn
because we were flooding their market
with with American produced corn that's
cheaper they were forced to migrate then
to make a living wage and that had been
historically you know that it was both
the the poor economic conditions in
Latin America that were forced people to
leave but then also the the
pull of you at the US labor market we
love undocumented labor and so we employ
these folks we tell them we hate you at
the border but we love you and you're in
the kitchen we love it when you're when
you're doing the landscaping so there is
this this pole as well that happens but
you know but now you know with the whole
migrant Caravan that's happening the
caravan these are folks who are leaving
places like Honduras because they are
literally running for their lives and
Honduras is a nightmare right now
I mean it's one of the most dangerous
places in the world people are literally
dying daily on the street because of
gang violence because of drug cartel
violence and so that's a different
reason for this out migration but we
have to know too that you know Latin
America Honduras El Salvador these
places are the way that they are because
oftentimes I pull it of us political
intervention we've done these things of
these countries that then have cleared
the conditions that then force them to
leave and then you've got things like
global warming that are pushing you know
hurricane Mitch in the in the 90s that
was something that created this new wave
of Honduran migrants that had to leave
because they could no longer live in
these these places and so it's a lot of
there's a lot of complex factors that
are that are both I think pushing and
pulling people out of these countries
and forcing them to make these these
incredibly difficult decisions to to
migrate that was a good run down of also
some of the history of of NAFTA a little
bit about what's going on in Honduras
this we don't we don't get this as part
of our our variable that we calculate
within our empathy know this so when we
get to hear it and we get to add it to
the calculation and the mixture of all
the perspectives we're trying to
synthesize into into how we feel about
what's going on in the world I think
that helps a lot now when when you're
when you're they're dealing with
artifacts
what are you finding because we see your
amazing art installation you made very
thought-provoking art installation of
the backpack wall again you can see that
right now
and then also I saw the video view with
you know you were seeing the leftover
water bottles you know tell us about
these artifacts and how do they add to
the narrative well for me that a big
part of the archaeology is to make this
stuff visible to say look people are out
in the desert they're crossing in the
middle of nowhere but they're leaving
behind these materials and for me the
archaeology part of it is is helping to
make this thing that's invisible visible
it's helping to document this historical
moments and as far as I'm concerned you
know the Arizona desert that is our new
Ellis Island you know that is that's a
part of American immigration history
it's incredibly polarizing at this
moment I mean we whether we like it or
not it's part of our shared immigration
history and so part of the archaeology
for me is both to understand what it
looks like on the ground but also to
make the case that that we need that we
need to document and and conserve these
materials for for humanity and one of
them you know for many many years I
fought with people who who hated the
fact that I was using archaeology in
this way they found that it was not
actually archaeology and I would say you
know what all archaeology is is a study
of the past through material culture
that past could be five minutes ago
there's no law that says it has to be
5,000 years ago and so it's fun it's for
me it's been a really interesting way to
use our ki ology in this in this new and
much and then I find a really compelling
kind of contemporary way but also to to
show like yeah this is American history
this is American history and so for many
years people are saying what you collect
is garbage and you know it's not
language that I use I'd say these are
things people have left behind in
distress it could be food wrappers water
bottles it could be Bibles baby bottles
personal letters things that they've
lost in routes but they're artifacts
these are artifacts and we treat them
with with a lot of respect and one of
the biggest I think proudest moments of
my life was when the Smithsonian a
sessioned you know hundreds of these
objects and they're on display now you
can go to the American History Museum
and see materials from the Arizona
desert next to the materials from from
Ellis Island because those curators
there do see the value and the
historical connections between these
between these materials good job yeah
good job man not a long fight I mean but
but I think it's a you know it's a
it really makes me makes me proud of the
work that my students have done and you
know and very grateful for for the
opportunities to to try to help tell
this story
Wow to be able to see the artifacts next
to Ellis Islands artifact no whoa no so
where where else do you think
contemporary archeology can be of use
it's happening now all over the place I
mean when when I started this project
the big the big kind of most well-known
version of this had happened in Tucson
Arizona funny enough you know but
looking at people's garbage
there was a Tucson garbage project where
they were excavating landfills they were
doing archaeology and people's dumpsters
to see what they were throwing away and
thinking about issues of consumption and
and waste but now you're seeing
contemporary archaeology happening all
over the globe we were just on a panel
with this afternoon with folks who do
the separate work in the Mediterranean
looking at that humanitarian crisis what
those refugees are leaving behind in the
water when they get to get to get to
Europe you've got folks doing this all
over the US in different context so I
mean I think archaeology is really
relevant and we're only now kind of
scratching the surface about the
different places that we can put we can
put it to use in a contemporary setting
but for me that's and that was not the
type of archaeology that I had been
trained to do yeah it's from stone
Junction stone tools to today some
archaeology yeah them from yesterday's
you know whoa in that that I think that
is such a profound augmentation to
people's awareness that that archaeology
can be from what happened yesterday so a
is howdy how do we figure out how to
immediately send safely send
archaeologists to the areas like in
Myanmar with the RO Higgins and being
displaced to Bangladesh how how do we
safely send archaeologists there to
start it's hard there's a lot of places
right now where we know archaeology
should happen but it's just too it's too
dangerous
I mean the Sahara people are coming from
West Africa the crossing the Sahara to
get to Libya and many of those refugees
will tell you the worst part
the journey is not the Mediterranean
where thousands of people have drowned
it's crossing the Sahara where thousands
of people if not more have died out
there and so we know there's archeology
out there in the making it's being made
right now in real time bodies being left
behind abandoned trucks and that kind of
stuff but it's not a place that you can
go to right now to do this kind of work
but but I do hope in the future that
there will be a moment of reconciliation
and where people will be able to get in
it I mean you look you look at like the
mass grave so from genocides it's it's
sometimes taking decades for us to be
able to get back in there to do this
work of identifying these bodies
Wow so safety for contemporary
archeology needs to be pushed we need to
make push for that that's also so
interesting now I wanna I want us just
here now maybe some of your information
synthesis about you know what about what
you've been teaching you've been
bringing students down you've been
teaching them about contemporary ecology
your exhibits now with Ellis Island what
is a huge synthesis for you of of this
you know I think that we need to see the
the historical connections between this
immigration wave and the ones that have
come before it
we need to see that every generation in
this country we have demonized
immigrants it used to not be cool to be
Irish right it used to not be a
welcoming Ellis Island was never a
welcoming place we've romanticized it a
hundred years later but when you were
you know you know Europeans coming to
Ellis Island were Boers were mistreated
and abused like much like Latinos are we
did the same thing to the Chinese to all
these different ethnic groups that have
come in these waves and so for me a big
part of it is to see that what's
happening now there's no different than
what's happened in previous generations
and we need to to fight against this
historical amnesia to see these
connections and I would hope that by
having information about how bad it was
for people's ancestors and there's no
difference people will say well my
answer just came here legally and they
worked really hard and learned English
into those like you know that in 50
years we're gonna be seeing that same
narrative about about Latinos and
there'll be some new group that people
will be demonizing and so for me it's
really important to to educate people
that what they think about what it used
to be like is probably not
not the case so that's a big part of it
another part of it too is to understand
that people aren't leaving their home
countries because they want to there's
all these things that are happening on
the back end that are pushing them out
and a lot of times it's US intervention
that is creating these these these
problems I mean the drug war in Mexico
we snort the cocaine and shoot the hair
went up that um that that we are paying
Mexico to produce Mexico is a war zone
because we send them guns I mean
something they're making these firearms
in Mexico so understanding those things
and how they're connected to this these
waves of migration I think is really
important and I think finally
understanding that millions of people
have crossed through the Arizona desert
because of a because of policies that
are in place along the border that
forced them into these areas in hopes
that if you have to walk five days
across the desert that you will stop
coming and and that it may kill you and
those are things that you can find
online I've written extensively about
those policies that explicitly say the
desert can kill people and that would be
a good strategy to deter them so I want
people to really understand that
thousands have died there are thousands
of identified bodies that have that it
will never be identified but people who
have died in this during this process
and this happens on US soil I mean more
people have died crossing the us-mexico
border than in died in 9/11 and if you
look at the maps
I mean it's we're talking this is a lot
of dead bodies and we should be we
should be ashamed and shocked and we you
know if you took these 3,000 bodies you
know 5,000 bodies however meant you know
what the depending on who you ask and
you put them in downtown San Jose right
you put them in you know in some other
part of the US it would be immediately
deemed a humanitarian crisis but the
fact that this happens in the middle of
nowhere people don't see it these are
often times let you know undocumented
Latinos that that a certain segment
thinks is not worthy of care people are
just like yeah whatever it's fine
illegal border crossers right they broke
a lock on the thing or I don't want to
hear about it but I think we need to
hear about it and we need to um we need
to be inspired to take action because
it's a troubling thing and we should be
really ashamed that our country does
these things to people we should be
ashamed leaders to each other I mean
it's just a basic human level yeah
there's got to be a major shift in
and in sinking into oneself in one's
heart and finding coherence and
residence with other humans not
dehumanizing people are different
economic and political roots of
civilization that must be augmented to
to transition to make that transition to
stewardship into just a different
resource flow of civilization all that
stuff um maybe the last thought for you
would be what is this is this the focus
for a while and you know what would be a
next for Jason well I'm working on the
book right now about smugglers whoa yeah
so I've been working with smugglers for
the last three or four years Honduran
smugglers who are crossing people
getting him across Mexico and part of
that work for me is oftentimes smugglers
are really if there's if there's a bad
guy to blame it's the smuggler it's the
smugglers fault that people that
migrants dies the smugglers fault that
they're coming in smoke probably someone
got assaulted I want people to
understand that smugglers are a natural
progression outcome of a political power
economic policies of labor market so
while we make smugglers we make these
folks who then get into this into this
this economic system that we benefit
directly from and so that's part of my
you know it and it's hard to write you
know can can you write us in a
sympathetic story about a smuggler and
should you and so that's one question
but for me it's like okay I don't want
to write a sympathetic story about a
smuggler I want to write a moving story
about a person who finds himself in a
situation where they have to make these
difficult decisions we all think that we
wouldn't be the yards at the Nazi
concentration camp yeah so I really want
to understand those things as one as one
other part of this problem because I
think that the immigration issue is so
complicated and we've got to understand
all these different parts and how
they're and how they fit together
we really look forward to smugglers we
don't really look forward to everything
that you're showcasing and building
congratulations on the amazing success
thank you thank you very much out of the
show and talking to us and thank you
everyone for tuning and give us your
thoughts in the comments below we'd love
to hear from you and check out Jason's
links also in the bio please go and
build the future go manifest your
destiny into the world ever
one huge thank you to triple-a our
partners thank you and we'll see you
guys soon peace Thanks